let's talk about uh representative
ayanna presley she is one of the squad
alongside such luminaries as aoc ilhan
omar and rashida talib and what these
people consistently do is they say
buzzwords endless endless buzzwords that
actually mean nothing but a certain
segment of society thinks that because
they've said x amount of nonsensical
buzzwords often things that none of us
said year you know four or five years
ago that that somehow gives them cachet
and value and it means that they're
making sense and then the media then
pushes these things because these are
the good guys and they're standing up
for all of these groups that they just
made up and everything else
and well here's exhibit a 2021 has been
the most devastating for abortion rights
in american history
in the midst of an ongoing global
pandemic that robbed us of more than six
hundred and ninety thousand lives and
disproportionately impacted our most
vulnerable and black and brown
communities anti-abortion legislators in
forty seven states focused on
legislating hurt and harm to push this
critical health care out of reach
these misguided bans will not actually
prevent all abortions they simply put
safe and necessary abortion care out of
reach for our most vulnerable
specifically our lowest income sisters
our queer trans and non-binary siblings
black latinx aapi immigrants disabled
and indigenous indigenous folks and none
of this is happenstance it is precise
like the roots of the anti-abortion
movement these bans are rooted in
patriarchy and white supremacy
god these people are just ridiculous
like where do i start first off if we
were just playing like meaningless
buzzword bingo it's like lady
congratulations you're getting a box of
donuts like jesus christ i would love to
know how she thinks that queer and gay
people are going to be struggling
because of the
these pro-life laws that she says are
being pushed by the way no one has has
banned abortion
no one has banned abortion period it's
against the law because of roe v wade
roe v wade is a federal law saying that
the states cannot make their own
decisions related to abortion that the
right to an abortion is a federal law
now we can argue whether that's a sane
uh decision or not or whether it should
be kicked back to the states but even in
texas which did pass this six-week law
it's not a ban on abortion you still
have six weeks to get abortion and and
again you guys know my feelings on this
like i don't even agree with the six
weeks thing but these people they just
say crazy things that first of all they
keep calling it health care and it's
like well it's not really health care
like you are killing a baby right like
depends on your definition i guess it's
loosely it's healthcare um but you know
and then of course she links it to the
patriarchy and white supremacy and the
rest of this nonsense it's affecting
black and latinx like find me a latino
who says latinx or lepinx please that
would be a pleasure aapi what's that
asian and pacific island or something
like that immigrants and disabled and
indigenous folks you see how they just
say these crazy things like is there
some massive problem we're having with
disabled people who want to have
abortions is that really think how
stupid that statement is like is there
really a problem indigenous folks are
having huge abortion like it's all
nonsense everything they say is nonsense
and but a certain amount of people hear
that and they go my god our low income
sisters and our queer and trans latinx
aapi brothers and sisters they're
hurting man we got to do something uh by
the way the democrats
voted just in the last couple days i
think we talked about it briefly last
week
to pass a bill
it passed 218 to 11 so i guess it didn't
actually pass right like that was just
how they voted on it
we'll get a little more info on this but
the democrats it's not a law yet but the
democrats voted 218 to 1
that a woman could have an abortion at
any stage in her pregnancy as long as
she had one health care professional
that said it was okay and that could
include mental health so you could be at
eight months and be freaking out for
good reason you know it's a lot of
stress to have a kid and you could be
like all right i'm gonna have an
abortion like that's how extreme these
people have become and it's like in a
sane society we would have an honest
debate about this stuff and we can as
you know talk about when the sperm meets
the egg talk about a few weeks where
it's mostly just a clump of cells talk
about when the heartbeat starts and all
of those things and i'm pretty well
versed in this as we're going through
surrogacy and believe it or not a couple
days in after the sperm meets the egg
you can know the sex the same people who
will tell you to believe in science and
that you know gender doesn't even exist
and it's like we know right now we have
a certain amount of male
embryos and we have a certain amount of
female embryos we don't have a certain
amount of oh pick your
gender embryos like that's not a thing
i'm fairly certain that my
our guy is a you know scientist he's a
man of science like he knows what he's
doing he's a fertility doctor he's not
like oh you know you got a ten embryos
here we got uh you know three male
three female and four you know they'll
decide like that's not a thing it's not
a thing anyway these people
they're just bananas